aujourd'hui un événement Amira c'est un vrai numéro
enquêtant sur le bombardement mon ami
suspect je suis désolé qui es-tu
tu vas me dire où la prochaine
attaque va être ça devient sage
tu veux seulement effacer mon nom ne
négocie pas  avec des terroristes, vous ne voulez
pas m'aider, je vous trouverai mr.  J'avais besoin de
personnes réellement responsables de cela J'ai
besoin de l'homme au masque
Mikhail a un super défiguré
après qu'un drone fume Johnny où se trouve une
entreprise américaine courageuse ici en ville
voyagez l'appareil avant que vous
progressiez mais il n'est pas alimenté par
batterie il  c'est à vous que nous nous enfermons en vous il
est alimenté par le président plus
son travail se poursuit pour que le sang
désactive l'arme et maîtrise le
partenaire le président doit être exécuté
j'ai le président vous devez l'abandonner
les américains exigent une action immédiate
après aujourd'hui  combien de temps avons-nous la
bombe n'est pas la fin vous vous montrez leurs
troncs vous les fantômes se lèvent les fonctionnaires
exhortent les habitants à rester calmes le
pays n'est pas la route il s'était encore arrêté
il n'y a pas de grande victoire dans la mort
vous